we're going to begin this hour with what
seems to be a growing shift in opinion
about the danger of sharks now safe to
say most people have at least some fear
of sharks but scientists believe that
that fear is not something that we are
born with but rather something that we
learn along the way and we probably have
hollywood to thank for that for decades
movies like jaws have fueled our fears
of great white sharks well this morning
carter evans takes us to the beach in
santa barbara california an area
considered to be a white shark nursery
and he's looking into what's really
behind that fear of sharks and why at
long last seems to be changing
within minutes of launching the drone i
found one we had our first sighting he
was right on the shore he is so close
it's a juvenile great white shark eight
to nine feet long in waist-deep water
off a popular santa barbara beach and
under the watchful eye of marine
biologists from the shark lab we go in
for a closer look oh he's right there he
is literally right here look his fin
just broke the surface right there for
many this is the stuff nightmares are
made of the shark
is right there just zip out 10 feet up
but scientists are learning our outsized
fear of so-called man-eating sharks is
unfounded the risk of shark attacks is
extremely low however people's
perceptions of the danger that those
kind of encounters pose tends to be much
higher psychologist gabriella hancock is
working with the shark lab at cal state
long beach to understand what makes
people so scared of sharks we're not
innately afraid of sharks five-month-old
babies we're not afraid of sharks so it
appears as though our fear of them is
learned and socially reinforced
it turns out
after falling into the water with that
juvenile great white the reaction to
scramble back onto the board isn't
necessary so this is the weird thing
right i'm 10 feet behind a large shark
bigger than i am i lose my balance i
fall in the water the shark takes off
even though these juveniles can be up to
nine feet long and 600 pounds they would
rather avoid something as big as a
person in fact if you do make a move
toward a shark
they tend to go the other way exactly we
see this over and over again shark lab
director chris lowe says these sharks
are actually afraid of us you can see
from above how they mostly avoid people
in the water but despite all the
evidence most people are still terrified
of sharks
scientists believe the 1975 movie jaws
caused a generation of people to develop
galeophobia an irrational fear of sharks
for many just two notes of the
soundtrack
is all it takes to trigger that fear
so jaws really had that much of an
influence on people oh it had a huge
influence it greatly changed how people
perceive sharks there's even a term for
it the jaws effect a belief that sharks
intentionally attack humans with popular
media it influences
people's attitudes and perceptions such
that it exaggerates the danger that
these animals pose so people feared them
which made it easy to kill them
and we basically sterilized our oceans
of
shark predators
author peter bensley who penned the book
that inspired the movie later said he
regretted writing it and was quoted
saying there's no such thing as a rogue
shark which develops a taste for human
flesh i think what we're starting to see
is that that jaws mentality is slowly
going away a deadly shark encounter dark
bite shark attacked media coverage of
shark attacks can still amplify people's
fears but it turns out these images of
sharks and people coexisting off the
coast appear to have a positive effect
there's growing evidence scientific
evidence that people's attitudes are
changing because they're getting good
information and it's that understanding
that takes away some of that fear and
when you consider countless interactions
like this are happening every day off
the southern california coast how rare
is a shark attack really shark bites are
powerball rare like your chances of
winning powerball are better than being
bitten by a shark but even faced with
slim odds that was amazing that's
actually the first time i've seen one in
the wild the fear of sharks is a hard
habit to break so positive emotion yes
nothing creeped into your head about
jaws or any of that nope i felt
perfectly safe on the boat if i asked
you would you get in the water with me
ah
i'm not equipped
okay okay i'll let you go
i cannot stress enough that these are
young great white sharks they haven't
learned to hunt large prey yet not like
they'd go after humans but they're more
likely to make a mistake when they're
hunting large prey if humans are in the
water next to seals that sort of thing
one of the big questions right now is
will these sharks return to these
nursery areas as adults well so far
none of the juvenile sharks that the
team have tagged have come back as
adults but that could happen guys
well carter listen you're armed with all
this knowledge so when you fell in the
water and that shark was very close to
you were you afraid
yes
yes i was i mean that's the initial
reaction
yeah and you know the funny thing is i
you know i i surf in these areas all the
time and i don't really think about it
but when you know the shark is there
it's a scary thing all of a sudden you
know there's this probability that
didn't exist before but i i'm trying to
think through this logically now and
understand that these predators are
around all the time whether i see him or
not
see i have the opposite uh effect on me
carter i think that if i'm surfing or
from you know on a kayak and i don't
know that a shark is there that's when
those attacks happen right because
they're often sneak attacks the shark
will hit you from below but if i can see
it i know how to avoid it that's the way
i think about it all i know is it's
dangling a foot in water
exactly it's a lot like fishing but
you're the bait
exactly i don't know but it is good to
know they don't want to hurt you that
they're more afraid of you than you are
of them but you look at their teeth and
all that logic to me goes out the window
but i know people that love sharks that
say we're the problem and not them so i
think the more educated we are the
better off we'll all be so thank you
thank you carter thank you for that